[Aplausos]
[Música]
hasta ahora la Guerra de Ucrania parece
la versión moderna del mito de David
contra Goliat casi un año después de que
los tanques rusos estuvieran a las
puertas de Kid Ahora son los rusos los
que parecen estar contra las cuerdas
Pero y si Moscú estuviese intentando a
cualquier precio revertir esta situación
podrían volver a cambiar las tornas pues
atentos a esta noticia Rusia completa La
movilización parcial de ciudadanos para
la Guerra de Ucrania esta noticia es de
noviembre de 2022 en el momento en el
que hacemos este vídeo enero de 2023
todavía no se sabe exactamente Cuántos
nuevos soldados ha conseguido movilizar
Rusia pero el objetivo eran 300.000 si
esto fuera así estaríamos hablando de
casi el doble de los soldados que
comenzaron a invasión en febrero del año
pasado pero no sólo eso algunos dicen
que las cifras podrían Ser aún mayores
atentos Ucrania dice que Rusia se
prepara para movilizar otros 500.000
reclutas extra Hasta qué puntos esto
cierto no lo sabemos pero todo señala
que algo se está cociendo y si la
inteligencia urnia no se equivoca Rusia
tendría ya más de 2 mil tropas en el
campo de batalla y ahora podría querer
sumar otras 500.000 más
[Música]
es decir que podríamos llegar a hablar
de más de 700.000 soldados en combate o
al menos listos para entrar en batalla
esto podría explicar por ejemplo porque
el arranque del año 2023 ha sido tan
frenético prácticamente cada día se
anuncian enormes envíos de armas pesadas
y misiles avanzados a Ucrania por parte
de los Estados Unidos Reino Unido y
demás países aliados por ejemplo
Dinamarca le ha entregado Ucrania el
grueso de su artillería fijaos Dinamarca
donara Ucrania 19 o buses otro
propulsados cesar de fabricación
francesa en otras palabras que hay que
preparar Ucrania porque 500.000 soldados
más reclutados son muchos soldados pero
respecto a Rusia ya sé lo que muchos
estaréis pensando cómo les han podido
entrenar En tan poco tiempo si en 2022
con los arsenales llenos de material los
rusos ya tuvieron problemas logísticos
Cómo van a armar y alimentar a
tantísimas personas Pues sí tenéis razón
enviar tantas tropas no estaría fácil y
como veremos más adelante en este vídeo
la movilización parcial de Putin ha sido
de todo menos un camino de rosas ahora
bien seguimos hablando de cientos de
miles de nuevos soldados podrán estar
mejor o peor armados con mejor o
entrenamiento o con más o menos
equipamiento pero como mínimo hay que
mirar estas cifras con respeto si
finalmente se produce Esta movilización
es una cifra lo suficientemente alta
como para que le dediquemos un vídeo
aquí en visualpolitik Así que la
pregunta que hoy nos hacemos Es de
verdad han sido capaces de reclutar a
tanta gente en Rusia como lo han hecho
Qué consecuencias puede tener todo esto
para el kremlin Hasta qué punto deberían
preocuparse en hoy vamos a responder a
estas preguntas pero antes vamos a ver
un poco de historia
todo vale para el convento
el 20 de diciembre de 2022 la duma que
es el parlamento ruso aprobó la ley de
movilización Rusia necesita 300.000
nuevos reclutas y la pregunta que muchos
os estaréis haciendo es Pero esto Qué
significa exactamente Es decir a partir
de ahora se puede enviar a cualquier
ciudadano ruso a la guerra como se ha
hecho esta movilización Pues bien lo
primero que tenemos que tener en cuenta
es que no todos los rusos pueden ser
llamados a filas el primer requisito es
tener experiencia militar previa Por
ejemplo si luchaste en la guerra de
Georgia de 2008 te podrían volver a
llamar de nuevo tendrías que pasar un
examen médico y podrías verte obligado a
irte a Ucrania que intentas escaparte
pues prepárate porque puedes terminar
con penas de entre 3 o 10 años de cárcel
hasta aquí todo Es lo normal no deja de
ser una guerra además el sueldo
prometido por Putin no está nada mal
Putin ha dicho que cada movilizado
cobrará 195.000 rubros que es el
equivalente a más o menos 3000 dólares
mensuales claro esto es la teoría porque
la práctica puede llegar a ser muy
diferente según un informe de 100
soldador ruso reclutado se declararon en
huelga y se negaron a luchar en Ucrania
después de que no se les pagase os
podéis imaginar el primer problema con
una movilización como esta es el coste
político es de cajón muy pocos están
felices con ir a la guerra
Así que Tan pronto como el kremlin hizo
el anuncio de la primera movilización se
organizaron las primeras protestas en
las principales ciudades del país y de
hecho desde entonces Putin ha reducido
considerablemente sus apariciones en
público por ejemplo cada final de año el
presidente ruso solía hacer una
conferencia de prensa con preguntas del
público pues bien en 2022 esta tradición
llegó a su fin la conferencia se canceló
Pero la pregunta ahora es Cómo se puede
reclutar a 300.000 personas primero y si
finalmente ocurre a medio millón más en
un país tan grande como Rusia Pues bien
cada región rusa tenía centros de
reclutamiento al que se les ponen unas
cuotas estos son los mismos Centros
donde se reclutan los 260.000 jóvenes
que hacen el servicio militar cada año y
aquí es donde viene el segundo gran
problema como os podéis imaginar muchos
rusos no quieren morir en Ucrania a
estas alturas todos habréis oído hablar
del Éxodo masivo de jóvenes rusos que se
han escapado de su país para evitar a la
guerra hablamos de más de 700.000
personas y qué creéis que ha pasado con
los que no han conseguido escaparse Pues
en muchos casos cosas como esta desde la
invasión de uc se han reportado más de
una docena de intentos de quemar
oficinas de reclutamiento en distintas
regiones rusas habéis oído bien No solo
hablamos de protestas hablamos de gente
que ha llegado a tirar cócteles Molotov
contra las oficinas de reclutamiento
hemos visto vídeos de protestas quejas
de reclutas etcétera vamos que esta
movilización masiva no ha sido para nada
tarea fácil sin embargo para el 28 de
octubre de 2022 el ministro de defensa
anunció que la primera movilización
había terminado con éxito y la pregunta
que muchos estaréis haciendo es de
verdad fueron capaces de movilizar a
300.000 soldados o es otro farol de los
muchos que lleva a Rusia tirándose en
esta guerra
pensadlo así todos los años el ejército
ruso hace dos campañas de reclutamiento
unas en primavera y la otra es en otoño
estas dos campañas duran alrededor de
tres meses ya que se movilizan unos
130.000 jóvenes cada campaña sin embargo
ahora Estamos hablando de movilizar a
más del doble de personas en menos de la
mitad de tiempo y además en mitad de
protestas con ataques con cócteles
Molotov de verdad es posible hacer algo
así pues bien lo que ya están diciendo
muchos expertos es que Rusia sí puede
movilizar a 300.000 reservistas ahora
bien con muchas comillas Por una parte
se han incluido a criminales que estaban
en prisión también se han cometido
errores como enviar a soldados que
superaban el límite de edad pero todo
esto son cosas que incluso el propio
kremlin ha reconocido sin embargo hay
sospechas de que el kit de la cuestión
no es exactamente este
Y es que veréis en teoría esta
movilización intentaba reenganchar a
reservistas con experiencia en combate o
que al menos hayan sido soldados
profesionales no simples reclutas pensad
que en Rusia casi todos los hombres de
entre 18 y 27 años tienen que hacer un
servicio militar obligatorio que dura 12
meses es decir que ahora mismo hay
127.500 reclutas que están a punto de
terminar sus 12 meses de servicio y
volver a sus trabajos civiles están
preparados para el combate evidentemente
no pero los centros de reclutamiento
necesitan cumplir con las cuotas que se
les han impuesto y si sois veteranos
seguidores de visualpolitik ya sabéis
que la administración rusa se
caracteriza por una cosa mentiras y más
mentiras los directores de los centros
quieren tener contentos a sus superiores
que a su vez quieren tener contentos al
Alto Estado Mayor Y así sucesivamente
conclusión como decimos en Castilla todo
vale para el convento ven acá Dimitri
tráeme a estos reclutales encasquetamos
un contrato de soldado profesional Y les
mandamos para Ucrania de cuantos
reclutas estamos hablando se está
haciendo de forma frecuente no lo
podemos saber pero desde luego Esta no
es una teoría para nada descabellada
ahora bien con más o menos experiencia
estaríamos hablando de decenas y decenas
de miles cientos de miles de personas
que poco a poco llegaron al campo de
batalla y la pregunta es hasta qué punto
pueden inclinar La balanza hacia Rusia
Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Música]
una picadora de carne
según el gobierno ruso para finales de
octubre y comienzos de noviembre de 2023
la primera movilización ya habría
cumplido su objetivo desde entonces
decenas y decenas de miles de estos
nuevos soldados han sido ya trasladados
a Ucrania la pregunta ahora es para qué
ha movilizado Rusia a tantas personas
Pues bien como puede parecer obvio el
primer objetivo ha sido reforzar las
debilitadas líneas rusas lo que ha
facilitado que en cierta forma el frente
se estanque o incluso que los rusos
hayan vuelto a intentar llevar a cabo
algunas pequeñas ofensivas Pero además
se cree que Rusia está planeando un
segundo gran ataque a Ucrania algunos
hablan de una ofensiva que empezaría a
finales del Invierno otros creen que se
esperarían hasta Primavera algunos dicen
que se limitarán simplemente al Don vass
pero la inteligencia ucraniana habla de
un nuevo ataque aquí un ataque que se
produciría desde Bielorrusia los rusos
están preparando tropas frescas no tengo
dudas de que irían otra vez por gif o
Alexander serkai Coronel general
ucraniano Claro que una cosa es reclutar
personas y otra muy distintas
prepararlas organizarlas y equiparlas y
creo que todos sabemos que Rusia está
teniendo muchísimos problemas para la
logística de lo que ya os hemos hablado
aquí en visualpolitik y también en
nuestra newsletter las claves de la
semana que publicamos todas las semanas
como su propio nombre indica para los
que nos seguís a través de patreon pero
es que además los Jennifer rusos no solo
están pensando en los repletamientos
también se ha visto como Rusia está
preparando tanques de 62 de los años 60
para enviarlos a Ucrania y esto en
cierta forma es un serio problema
porque por muchos soldados que logren
movilizar lo más probable es que el
grueso del armamento pesado quemando en
Ucrania de intentar otro golpe sea
morraya con alguna pieza más moderna
suelta por aquí por allá para las
misiones más complejas pero lo cierto Es
que pese a todas las bajas y pérdidas
sufridas a Rusia todavía les queda
muchísima morralla soviética por soltar
sea como sea desde el Instituto para el
estudio de la guerra han reportado que
las tropas rusas están trasladando más
equipamiento pesado el traslado está
siendo desde la retaguardia de Luján
hasta áreas cercanas al actual línea de
frente entre harkid y lujans y de hecho
es en esta región donde probablemente se
centran los rusos al igual que en el
oblas de donest donde intentarían
capturar la totalidad de la a lo largo
de estas líneas por ejemplo ya se están
realizando algunas operaciones limitadas
para frenar los avances ucranianos y
recuperar posiciones perdidas en el
frente de kremina y algo muy parecido
dice el propio ministro de asuntos
exteriores de Ucrania dimitro culeva
todos esperan una gran ofensiva rusa en
los primeros meses del año 2023
[Música]
sin embargo debido al poco entrenamiento
de muchos de estos movilizados tampoco
es que se espere demasiado de ellos y ya
sé lo que pensará alguno ya están los de
visualpolitik con su propaganda anti
rusa pues para nada de hecho algunos
movilizados sí pueden servir para mucho
al ejército ruso por ejemplo aquellos
con experiencia anterior en profesiones
como la mecánica o la medicina pueden
ser de gran ayuda pero en líneas
generales en toda Guerra y más aún en
Las Guerras modernas el entrenamiento y
la experiencia es un elemento muy pero
que muy importante no todos los soldados
tienen el mismo nivel combativo y vale
Es cierto que una parte de los
movilizados fueron enviados al frente
Mientras que el resto se quedaron
entrenando en Rusia sin embargo hasta
ahora no podemos decir que haya salido
demasiado bien la primera toma de
contacto y los que siguen entrenando
tampoco es que vayan a tener mucho
tiempo Este es un hándicap muy
importante que explica por qué en la
mayoría de los casos la movilización se
ha convertido en un verdadero infierno
para los rusos que la han sufrido
literalmente la mayoría no son más que
Carne de cañón que termina siendo
lanzada por Putin para hacer bulto en el
frente y tratar de retrasar un poquito
más a los ucranianos quizás esperando a
que el fin gobierno juega a su favor
evidentemente las expectativas de esta
gente son bastante malas y de hecho
muchos de ellos lo saben perfectamente
dos semanas de entrenamiento no te
preparan para esto declaraciones de un
movilizador Ruso adegardia aquí tenemos
el caso de
alexeynoff que fue movilizado junto a
otros 570 hombres de la región de
boronés en una entrevista que dio
adecardian contó su desastrosa
experiencia en el frente entre otras
cosas declaró que de los 570 reclutados
a las pocas semanas sólo quedaban 130
con vida muchos de los que sobrevivieron
perdieron la cabeza después de lo que
pasó nadie quiere volver estábamos
completamente expuestos declaraciones de
movilizador ruso de guardia pero esperad
un momento porque este no es el mayor
problema cierto todo apunta que estos
movilizados no están bien entrenados
pero la siguiente pregunta que nos
deberíamos hacer es cómo van a ir
armados Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
de dónde saldrán las armas
[Música]
hay una pregunta que voy a dejar en el
aire haced la suma 700.000 rusos y han
ido del país y otros 300.000 se van a
Ucrania en total hablamos de un millón
de trabajadores que se han ido del país
estamos hablando tranquilamente de más
del 1,4% de la población activa del país
y algo más del 2% si finalmente se
produce ese segundo reclutamiento Estos
son palabras mayores sobre todo cuando
tenemos en cuenta que entre los rusos
que han oído se encuentran muchos
jóvenes altamente cualificados y si a
esta pérdida le sumamos que la sociedad
rusa está profundamente envejecida a la
pregunta es cómo van a poder producir
riqueza la economía rusa Quién va a
fabricar esas armas que tanto necesitan
ahora mismo sí es cierto uno de los
grupos excluidos de la movilización son
precisamente los que trabajan en las
empresas de armamento Pero eso no es
suficiente Y ojo porque esto es algo que
reconocen las propias autoridades rusas
atentos la escasez de personal en las
empresas de defensa rusa es de alrededor
de 400.000 personas aunque esto no es
algo nuevo en otros vídeos ya os hemos
comentado los problemas armamentísticos
de Rusia en el año 2017 np o novator que
es una empresa armamentística rusa solo
era capaz de producir misiles en seis
meses y claro como os podéis imaginar la
intensidad de la Guerra de Ucrania
requiere un ritmo de producción mucho
más frenético que eso Por ejemplo para
que os hagáis una idea varias ocasiones
Rusia ha llegado a lanzar más del doble
de esa cantidad de misiles en un solo
día
[Música]
y no solo eso se estima que tan solo en
noviembre de 2022 Rusia disparó cerca de
20.000 rondas de artillería además en un
mes han llegado a lanzar Ni más ni menos
que 1200 misiles calibre según el royal
United service institute Rusia llegó a
disparar en dos días más municiones que
las que Reino Unido tienen su reservas
regulares además las fuerzas rusas ya
utilizaron casi el total de sus misiles
de corto alcance
[Música]
vamos que el ejército ruso tiene
simultáneamente dos grandes problemas
por un lado disparan artillería un ritmo
muy rápido y por el otro tienen grandes
problemas para producir más al ritmo
necesario Y es que al contrario de lo
que quizás pensaba Putin china no le ha
vendido armas de forma masiva como se
había especulado al comienzo de la
guerra y si esto ya es en sí preocupante
para Rusia hay otro factor que les ponen
las cosas un peor las sanciones
internacionales
[Música]
pensadlo así una cosa son las balas
convencionales que usamos para un rifle
y otra muy distinta los misiles de alta
precisión para fabricar balas normales
Rusia tiene los materiales y lo único
que le puede fallar un poco es la
industria y el ritmo de producción Pero
qué pasa con los misiles de precisión
Hay amigo aquí estamos hablando de un
juego totalmente distinto porque gran
parte de los misiles rusos están
equipados con Microchips
tradicionalmente suministrados por
occidente Y eso significa que debido a
las sanciones Rusia se está quedando sin
misiles de precisión por la escasez de
estos chips atentos según un informe las
armas rusas en Ucrania están alimentadas
por cientos de componentes occidentales
y es que claro la mayoría de estas
piezas accidentales se fabrican en solo
unos pocos países principalmente
hablamos de Taiwán Corea del Sur Estados
Unidos Países Bajos Alemania Reino Unido
y Japón es por esto que en Rusia hemos
empezado a ver todo tipo de champús
armamentísticas que parecen sacadas de
una película de risa atentos tenemos
informes de los ucranianos de que cuando
encuentran equipos militares rusos están
semiconductores que sacaron de
lavavajillas y neveras Gina raimondo
secretaria de comercio de los Estados
Unidos quién sabe igual eso explica las
imágenes que hemos visto de casas
ucranianas totalmente desvalijadas sin
frigoríficos ni lavadoras tras el paso
de las tropas rusas pero claro teniendo
todo esto en cuenta la pregunta es que
está haciendo Vladimir Putin para
cambiar esto
[Música]
Pues bien todas las sanciones en
realidad Putin tienen muy poco margen de
maniobra por ahora El dictador ruso está
aprovechando de su buena relación con la
República islámica de Irán un ejemplo
los constantes ataques controles iraníes
que ya se han convertido en algo
cotidiano en esta Guerra de Ucrania y
ojo porque a los drones les siguen los
misiles balísticos de corto alcance de
tipo fate 110 hizo alfagar por eso como
respuesta a la venta de armas de Irán
algunos países como el Reino Unido ya
han introducido nuevos paquetes de
sanciones no solo contra altos
gerifaltes del ejército ruso sino
también contra empresarios y
funcionarios iraníes el propio
secretario de estado de Estados Unidos
Anthony blinken dijo lo siguiente
Estados Unidos seguirá usando toda
herramienta a su alcance para
interrumpir dichas transferencias e
imponer consecuencias aquellos
involucrados en esas actividades Anthony
blink el secretario de estado de los
Estados Unidos de América por otro lado
desde Estados Unidos ha habido
acusaciones de compra de armas por parte
de Rusia a Corea del Norte acusaciones
que como no han sido tachadas por Rusia
de puras habladurías y especulaciones El
caso es que con o sin los norcoreanos
los rusos ya han empezado a utilizar
munición degradada en algunos casos
estaríamos hablando de cohetes y Balas
fabricadas hace más de 40 años y Qué
pasa cuando usas cosas viejas y
obsoletas pues lo que todos os podéis
esperar hay proyectiles que se atascan
en los buses rusos otros que son
lanzados pero que no explotan cuando
alcanzan su objetivo y ojo no os
equivoquéis porque esto puede ser algo
bueno es decir otra ventaja para gif en
el desarrollo de la guerra pero lo
cierto Es que tampoco son buenas
noticias para Ucrania en el largo plazo
por un lado Es verdad que es difícil
ganar una guerra con munición desfasada
Pero eso también significa que los
proyectiles que todavía no han explotado
pueden hacerlo más adelante en
circunstancias indeseadas pero no solo
eso dado que Rusia está siendo incapaz
de ganar la guerra ahora está empezando
a señalar y atacar objetivos más fáciles
Aunque eso suponga perpetrar crímenes de
lesa humanidad estoy por supuesto
hablando de los objetivos civiles algo
que ahora Rusia está empezando a buscar
para desanimar la resistencia ucraniana
el ataque de misiles rusos contra un
edificio de apartamentos y Pro mató a 40
personas Según dicen las autoridades
ucranianas pensadlo así qué utilidad
estratégica puede tener destruir un
edificio de viviendas desde el punto de
vista de la guerra ninguna Por qué los
cazas de combate rusos planean un ataque
así pues la razón es simple no pueden
hacer otra cosa y con estos ataques tan
crueles esperan poder desanimar la
resistencia y forzar Ucrania aceptar un
alto al fuego conveniente para Moscú es
exactamente lo mismo que han estado
haciendo con las centrales eléctricas o
con las plantas de tratamiento de agua
concretamente el ataque de deni Pro se
realizó con misiles kh22 estos misiles
son de la época soviética se
caracterizan por dos cosas son muy poco
precisos pero a la vez son casi
imposibles de interceptar por Ucrania al
menos con el Arsenal que tiene por ahora
conclusión Rusia los ha utilizado en
varias ocasiones para atacar zonas muy
pobladas de nuevo no destruyen un
objetivo militar concreto pero basta con
que caigan en una ciudad para que maten
a decenas de civiles
he llegado desde este punto Ya sé lo que
estaréis pensando muchos Entonces está
Rusia condenada a perder esta guerra
todos estos cientos de miles de nuevos
soldados van a ir directamente a una
picadora de carne Pues en cierto modo
Sí y a la vez no porque tenemos que
mirar la otra cara de la moneda
[Música]
Ucrania depende totalmente de las ayudas
de occidente para armar a su ejército y
aunque hasta ahora el suministro de
armamento Ucrania ha sido constante y
todo apunta que seguirá siendo así lo
cierto es que al final Esto es algo que
no depende de los ucranianos sino de la
solidaridad internacional y esto podría
llegar a ser un problema o como poco una
importante debilidad y segundo Aunque
occidente continúe suministrando
munición el arsenal de Europa y Estados
Unidos también tiene sus límites y la
situación ahora mismo Está lejos de ser
ideal al menos en lo que concierne a
determinados equipos y aunque parece que
todavía no estamos en un punto alarmante
Lo cierto es que noticias como éstas son
importantes y deberíamos tomarnoslas en
serio Europa está enviando armas Ucrania
rápidamente pero se está quedando sin
munición esto es un problema
especialmente en Europa occidental que
es la que tiene los ejércitos Pero
equipados quizás la única excepción sea
Reino Unido Estados Unidos por su parte
está echando mano de los gigantescos
almacenes que tenían Israel y Corea del
Sur para situaciones de guerra esto por
sí mismo debería servir para cubrir las
necesidades de munición convencional sea
como sea todavía no estamos en un punto
crítico las últimas entregas de armas
son una buena prueba de ello todavía
quedan muchos almacenes repletos pero
llegados a este punto La pregunta es
para vosotros está Ucrania preparada
para lo que parece que viene creéis que
los rusos reclutados van a cambiar de
verdad la dinámica de la guerra podéis
dejarnos vuestras opiniones abajo en los
comentarios y como siempre no olvidéis
Que aquí en visualpolitik sacamos vídeos
nuevos Todas las semanas así que
suscribíos a este canal y darle a la
campanita para no perderos ninguna de
nuestras actualizaciones si os ha
gustado este vídeo dadle a like y nos
vemos en el próximo un saludo y hasta
pronto
[Música]